[Musique]
cette grand honneur pour la céleste
bartik de football puisque samedi
prochain elle sera face au canada pour
le match inaugural de la gold cup
version 2019 bonjour josé goron bonjour
moi je vous invitais auditrice de mars
qui pourrait bien merci d'être avec nous
on va pas me rappeler josé que vous êtes
membre actif des chiens bull
cette émission animée par paulo lorsque
la sélection joue lorsqu'il est question
de football sur notre antenne
accessoirement vous êtes attaquant du de
l'aiglon du lamentin avec combien de
buts cette année j'en ai fait quatorze
14 ans championne heures d'être un des
meilleurs attaquants de notre football
martiniquais encore en activité un
ancien de la sélection de martinique la
gold cup en ans par josé goron match
inaugural
ce sera au rose bowl de los angeles au
stade qui peut accueillir jusqu'à 95
mille personnes rien qu'avec cette
capacité du stade on doit le dire on
change déjà deux dimensions
ben oui c'est à dire que on change de
dimension je pense que la section
démenti n'est qu'un habitué puisque
c'est la cinquième gold cup
ils ont fait de 2002-2003 mai 2013 2017
et maintenant en 2019
donc forcément on a des joueurs qui sont
déjà chevronné pour cela on a des
joueurs qui sont dans cette sélection
pour la gold cup 2010 9 qui ont
participé à la gold cup 2013 et 2017
donc forcément ils ont déjà assez
d'expérience pouvoir supporter cette
capacité des stones de 95 inopportun
15000 places
ouais ça forcerait pas de cette gold cup
c'est notre coupe du monde à nous fasse
rich dans notre groupe face au mexique
au canada cuba l'ordre dans ce groupe ce
sera surtout le mexique
oui le mec c'est une autre façon ils ont
un nouveau sélectionneur déjà donc celui
à dire que ce sectionnelles avec sa
sélection à
il faut savoir que le mexique participer
à la gold cup avec une sélection de
moins de 23 ans
hélas cette année ils viennent avec les
mexicains viennent avec
leur équipe face à dieu que les joueurs
qui ont participé à la coupe du monde
l'année dernière faisait du très lourd
si les traits nous donc je pense que
cette sélection a pour ambition de
gagner la gold cup ce sera le favori pas
du groupe mais de la gold cup et c'est
ce que nous ne sommes les petits poucets
mais nous avons aussi des atouts à faire
valoir
et puis cette compétition le rappeler
c'est pas seulement pour nous l'occasion
d'être confronté à d'autres nations de
la zone mais pour ces autres pays
justement d'amérique centrale d'amérique
de la caraïbes et d'amérique du nord
il ya une question de suprématie
régionale wissous et massy régionales
mais ce sont remboursés nationale à nous
nous arrivons comme j'ai dit
précédemment un petit poucet çà dire que
nous nous sommes un peu limité dans les
compétitions c'est vrai que ils ont créé
une compétition qui la ligue des nations
de la concacaf
donc ça permet aussi d'avoir une bonne
visibilité du football martiniquais du
football local est forcément pas passé
national un autre monde savait
pertinemment que ces saisies nationales
participent à la coupe america la coupe
du monde
nous nous sommes limités à la concacaf à
la digicel cup mais nous avons la
possibilité avec l'agglo comme de
pouvoir exposer notre on va quand même
pas où on va leur rappeler pour pour
ceux qui auraient encore quelques doutes
dans cette compétition de la tôle que
pelé pays qu'on peut rencontrer
on a parlé du mexique le canada et qui a
déjà joué en phase finale de coupe du
monde il ya le pays hôte les états unis
d'autres dations plus proche de nous que
nous connaissons bien haïti trinidad le
panama que du lot alors josé face à tout
ce beau monde quelles peuvent être les
atouts de notre sélection des atouts
donc déjà l'expérience parce que
sur sur les golfs précédente bande nous
n'avons pas été vraiment ridicule c'est
sûr qu'on avait eues l'apprécier de se
qualifier mais pas des comptes de six
ans qu'on connaît l'année en 2017 savait
que le match perdu par la guyane sous
tapis vert qui nous éliminer en 2013 on
n'a rien on a été éliminés au goal
avérage aussi par un match qui avait
entre cuba et belize et il fallait pas
que cuba guen pas trop medica dont je
pense que on a des joueurs chevronnés
des joueurs qui ont participé à léa
d'ego cup précédente et ses joies là je
pense qu'ils connaissent déjà la
compétition on à la part de
professionnels je pense qu'on a des
atouts si on a la notion de groupe voit
la solidarité de l'équipe qui doit vous
les rencontrez les joueurs de la
sélection des matinino vous les
rencontrez vous les avez senti motivé
avant de partir c'est peut-être façon
sans pouvoir aller les rencontrer ce la
motivation est là vous c'est la céda la
petite coupe du monde de la martinique
si la gauche était heureux que vous
étiez en sélection pour pour cette gold
cup
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qui se passait chez
vous c'est à dire que vous allez j'ai
une très bonne motivation
il ya de l'émotion aussi parce que bon
vous avez participé à une compétition
qui est très médiatisée et très prisée
dans la caraïbe au niveau des amériques
et c'est sûr que quand vous rencontrez
des équipes comme le mexique comme des
états unis quand vous avez line et puis
vous avez un stade plein rempli puisque
bon dans le groupe on est je pense que
la communauté mexicaine sera là il sera
présenté en ce moment il ya beaucoup
d'émotions et puis il ya surtout une
très grosse motivation et l'envié de
bien faire
ouais est pas là pas peur d'être
ridicule on n'y pense pas il faut pas y
penser
alors pour revenir au groupe une demi
douzaine de professionnels autour des
joueurs de chez nous est ce qu'il faut
éternellement refaire le débat est ce
qu'on doit jouer avec le groupe de notre
championnat qu'on voit tous les samedis
tous les week-ends ici pour les
qualifications pu faire venir des
professionnels pour la phase finale
c'est à dire qu'il y avait deux
challengers c'est à dire que faire
participer un maximum de locaux deux
tiers de locaux et un tiers de pro
je pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
le football martiniquais pour nos
joueurs locaux de pouvoir se mesurer à
des équipes des nations comme le mexique
les états-unis autres et c'est sûr que
ça permet aussi de développer notre
football de connaître le haut niveau que
des jeunes poupin peuvent s'exprimer
pouvoir pourquoi pas avoir une
possibilité de tenter une carrière
professionnelle être vu dans l'accueil
même dans les amériques et ses cieux que
ce serait quand même dommage d'avoir des
noms locaux qui participe à la
qualification collègues cup et ne pas
les retrouver à la compétition celle ci
se voit
il faut savoir aussi que l'inconvénient
que les procès que vous plaît pas vous
pouvez pas les avoir tout le temps
durant la saison alors je voulais
terminer par cette question doit la
poser tout de suite les des joueurs de
la sélection sont partis il ya quelques
jours pour leur préparation
lorsqu'on part pour une telle
compétition est ce qu on pense par
exemple à la fin de la saison et à la
nouvelle saison qui va arriver vous
savez ce fameux cette fameuse période de
mutation et comme on gère ça est-ce
qu'on signe avec son nouveau club
est ce qu'on décide de rester dans son
club l'a mieux psychologiquement c2c de
gérer avant la compétition de pouvoir
s'organiser de prévoir si vous avez
envie de quitter le club a envie de
changer de club donc je pense que ce
serait mieux de s'organiser avril sauf
une excellente kong cup on peut signer
ailleurs on peut être vu remarqué repéré
à mais je pense que ces paliers sa nuque
à bout pu voir c'est par des équipes
extérieures des équipes pro ben il ya
matière même si vous signer dans un club
en martinique je pense que la priorité
je pense que les organisations des
négociations entre le club occupe et
plus l'on pourra alors vous ai parlé de
longvic qui peut être une donnée
psychologique très importante lorsqu'on
lorsqu'on aborde une telle compétition
on devra compter sur quoi d'autre parce
que l' envie c'est bien beau mais ya pas
que ça vous avez vous avez un goût vous
avez une équipe vous avez déjà une des
qualités intrinsèques que vous avez des
atouts à faire valoir aux avants
sélectionneur qui met des plans en place
qui me système de jeu en place et puis
je pense que le sélectionneur il a il a
une très bonne sélection je pense qu'il
depuis le début il a eu
là ils apprenaient la notion de bloc
équipe de groupes de cohésion de groupe
savait bien que ce groupe là n'a pas
beaucoup bougé depuis depuis le début de
la campagne
donc c'est sûr qu'avec l'apport de
professionnels la mode deux joueurs qui
ont touché au niveau qu'ils ont le
niveau aussi international ça ça permet
aussi de d'élever le niveau de l'équipe
il permet donc aux joueurs locaux
d'élever le niveau s'ils allaient partir
à portland que plusieurs jours avant le
début de la compétition pour pour
resserrer les rangs pour se faire au
climat à tout cela c'est ça mais c'est
quand même si ça coûte cher parce que on
entendu certaines crises quand même et
ce à un coût mais si vous voulez être
que bien vous si vous voulez bien
représenter votre sélection ça passe par
là et c'est pas propre à la station de
la matinée que c'est pour pas toutes les
sélections de partir peut-être une
semaine avant et bien se préparer et
créer une cohésion de groupe de façon à
bien démarrer la compétition on va faire
quelque chose que vous adorerez josée
gauvin que nous tous nous adorons
puisque nous sommes tous des
sélectionneurs potentiels
nous sommes même des joueurs potentiels
et potentiels football fiction
une victoire et un nul c'est suffisant
ou pas c'est oui face au canada face à
face à son exécution part du principe
que le mexique gagné ses trois matchs je
pense qu'avec quatre points c'est
suffisant c'est vrai qu'on a on a eu la
possibilité d'être meilleur troisième
lot des précédents gold cup
on est en trois points et on s'est fait
éliminer en angola virage
donc je pense qu'avec une victoire et un
match nul c'est ce que suffisant alors
la victoire ce serait face à qui face au
canada face à cuba
c'est à dire que le mieux c'est ce que
gagner le premier match mais
paradoxalement la martinique lors des
deux procès aux cubs avaient gagné le
premier match et ne s'était pas qualifié
donc forcément c'est sûr que pour avoir
pour être dans une dynamique positive ce
serait bien de gagner le premier ou
encore ne pas le perdre et gagner le
deuxième mais bon la foule debout n'est
pas une sensation du football fiction
lorsqu on entre sur un terrain est ce
qu'on a en tête toutes ces statistiques
des rencontres précédentes 93 ou fait
d'une bague est à 2004 nous fait-elle
bagages on oublie ce nouveau match qui
commence je pense que ça c'est c'la
briefing d'avant-match
ouais ça dès qu'on peut en parler lors
de celle-ci ne peut revenir dessus mais
lorsque vous êtes dans votre match vous
ne pensez pas 2004 2010 et 2013 dans ses
c'est la réalité du joker c'est aux
cayes à pandev et un plan
mis en jeu par par le sélectionneur il
ya un système
il ya des consignes à respecter je pense
pas qu'il faut dépenser suivi est-ce
qu'on a gagné par exemple en maturité en
ce qui concerne le respect des consignes
oui quand même
oui oui ça devant les résultats actuels
de la sélection de la martinique les
qualifications pour les gold cup les
victoires la passivité de la
participation à la ligue des nations de
la concacaf je pense que c'est justement
toutes ces compétitions on va commencer
par le championnat par la ligue
le trophée mutuelle mare gaillard toutes
ces compétitions lorsque le club
franciscain va participer à nos
championnats de coca caf des clubs
amateurs tout cela ça fait que
globalement notre niveau monte
est ce à dire qu'en participant déjà
joueurs de l'éveil des trois idées du
stade spiritains ou de l'été celle de
bakouba bénéficient de cette expérience
mais c'est le plafond si ça peut les
motiver à y arriver ou bien à être cotée
pas un club qui joue la provoc off
c'est sûr que quand jean la concacaf ça
permet d'élever le niveau quand même de
se frotter au gratin caribéen en termes
de football et c'est ce que ça permet de
grandir aussi de progresser et vous avez
des jeunes gens aussi qui ont participé
à la banque à qui je pense ont pris en
maturité et en expérience et ça pue se
répercuter sur l'a75 et surtout le
football martiniquais josé goron vous
avez vu la concurrence des autres
computer compétition continentale la
coupe du monde féminine le tournoi
espoirs de toulon la copa america
bientôt le championnat d'afrique des
nations ça fait beaucoup de football n'y
a pas un risque de lassitude de 7,2
cette discipline même si même si nos
joueurs seront sur le terrain non pas
par les téléspectateurs pour les
auditeurs
non pas du tout c'est à dire est que
savait l'espace est le leitmotiv de
beaucoup de gens et c'est sûr qu'à voir
toutes ces compétitions là c'est
intéressant quand c'est médiatisé c'est
bien beau si vous êtes footballeur si
vous êtes sportif c'est intéressant de
pouvoir regarder tout cela mais c'est
pas professionnellement football vous
avez la rétine vous avez le basket vous
avez le monde
donc forcément je pense que le sport
permet aussi à certains d'évacuer
évacuer 2
se trouvait l'association bien-être par
rapport à la vie ya des choix à faire
lorsque vous devez regarder je sais pas
moi brésil l'argentine en copa america
et puis que le même jour la martinique
contre amiens il faut faire un choix
personnel mancilla brésil l'argentine et
martinez que canada au martini cuba je
regardais martin et cuba et puis surtout
il ya le replay dernière question je
vous ai couru nous reste à peine
quelques secondes mais vraiment très
rapidement pour un joueur de la
sélection avant une faire une belle
performance et viser ensuite pour les
joueurs les plus méritants
le marché hexagonal la ligue 1 ou bien
déjà déjà fait bonne figure ex la
sélection ouais déjà avant de mon
résultat class action et par la suite
l'individu elle viendra après d'accord
merci josé goron d'avoir été avec nous
pour toucher rendez vous sur notre
antenne ce sera votre chien bull cet
après midi mais à 16h chez bull à josé
goron l'un des meilleurs attaquants du
football martiniquais 14 buts cette
année une centaine de budget avec le
bois de la majorité avec nous ce matin
dans son caddie merci bonne journée
[Musique]